un saludo a todos ustedes y desde
colombia les tratamos el siguiente
informe el ministerio de transporte en
vista de que el paro de camioneros se
fortaleció estableció unas mesas de
negociación y ayer a entre las 5 de la
tarde y las 10 de la noche se hizo una
reunión a la cual se están llegando a
los siguientes acuerdos por ejemplo se
pidió que se le reconociera al camionero
tradicional el precio mínimo de lo que
costaría un flete en condiciones
normales esto en razón a que los
intermediarios de carga se quedan hasta
con el 50 por ciento del flete que que
paga un generador de la carga
el ministerio ya expidió el primer
documento donde hace obligatorio que el
sistema de costos eficientes se respete
y que no se puede apagar por debajo de
lo que arroja esta tabla ese es el
primer punto el segundo punto es que
tenemos una
y una resolución que es perversa en el
sentido en que beneficia al camión viejo
y castiga al camión nuevo poniendo en un
orden de retraso la modernización de la
flota esto es que el camión viejo tiene
más preferencia y más beneficio que lo
que tendría un camión nuevo el
ministerio de transporte se compromete a
hacer una resolución para que todos los
camiones tengan los mismos beneficios y
preferencia ando en todo momento en la
seguridad en las vías también tiene unos
puntos adicionales como que en el
sistema de pensiones y parafiscales en
colombia que el distrito está haciendo
unos cobros excesivos al camionero
tradicional por la cantidad de dinero
que ellos nueve en razón de su trabajo
quiero preguntarle sobre el tema alberto
precisamente disculpe que lo interrumpa
pero es que tenemos poco tiempo y
quisiera abarcar la mayor cantidad de
temas porque la de usted
es una de las protestas que genera mayor
presión a el gobierno en el día 14 de
paro con todas estas exigencias que
ustedes están haciendo hay unos 120
bloqueos de vidas que ya se empiezan a
notar con desabastecimiento en algunas
ciudades y le quiero preguntar ustedes
creen que esta es la única manera para
que el gobierno los escuche hasta cuando
irán los bloqueos teniendo en cuenta el
panorama de escasez de alimentos y de
medicamentos y además en medio de la
pandemia
bueno lo que quiero decirle es que no se
debe estigmatizar ni culpar a una acción
de defensa que están haciendo los
camineros tradicionales por cambiar el
camionero toma una vía de hecho porque
el el gobierno desde su posesión se ha
negado a prestarle las soluciones que
está exigiendo el camionero la única
solución que tiene el camionero es no
cargar y no cargar es que el país se
desabastece nosotros como representantes
del sector tradicional de carga estamos
absolutamente seguros que si el
camionero tradicional para la economía
se paraliza como efectivamente está
ocurriendo si el gobierno no sé si
conoce de esta situación pero nunca le
dio solución a las peticiones de
nosotros la misma ministra de transporte
dice que ha hecho 280 mesas de trabajo
con nosotros eso es cierto pero 280
mesas de trabajo
nunca tomo decisiones y de ahí que
llegamos a este escenario que estamos
viendo y por eso le quiero preguntar
pues otro tema es qué elementos están
ustedes dejando pasar por los corredores
humanitarios porque los productores pues
evidentemente como usted lo describe ya
están desesperados porque tienen su
producto varado en las fincas y con
posibilidad de perderse o hay ejemplos
como el de la industria avícola que no
tiene concentrado para alimentar a los
animales y le pido muy rápidamente que
ya se nos va acabando el tiempo
los campesinos que apoyan el paro
camionero porque los campesinos dicen
que muchas veces y han perdido las
cosechas por culpa del gobierno que si
en este momento tienen una perdida pero
que van a tener un un respaldo y un
beneficio apoyando el paro caminero lo
están haciendo
o sea que el campesino está apoyando el
paro nacional y en el caso de la
industria de la industria vinculada a
estas cuestiones se están haciendo lo
que nosotros denominamos corredores de
vida que es que únicamente pasan por
estos sitios alimentos alimentos para
los animales avituallamiento para
a las ciudades medicinas gases oxígeno
etcétera lo que no está pasando son los
otros productos que realmente no son
digamos como tan necesarios en este
momento pero los de primera necesidad
los esenciales si están pasando lo
estamos dejando pasar en los 120 puntos
de paro a nivel nacional